because he's so savvy with the media and
he understands that i'm going to
introduce him twice i'm going to bring
taylor lawan on right now how are you
taylor
i'm great i'm great you know what after
hearing about the peacock app i am
dialed in i'm going to get that as soon
as this is over you know what
let's just say that that's is this the
taylor lawn that said he was following
me years ago but really wasn't or is
this a taylor one that i've known since
the beginning of
time i'm careful tell her this is i feel
like this is
this is tough it's tough for me to
answer this i can't control what happens
when my phone is in my pocket all right
things happen but
as you know to unfollow somebody it
takes a couple steps or a couple cheeks
it takes a couple cheeks must be the
universe telling us something but you
know what i'm going to ignore the
universe's plan right now because i'm
enjoying this conversation
all right taylor so i'm about 30 seconds
back until the nbcsn audience
joins the show because this show is so
big it can't be distributed just by
one method of distribution um and
certain radio stations will rejoin us in
a second so um
how much time to we're back to 20
seconds so in about 20 seconds
we can buy in 20 seconds here's a quick
way easy way to do 20 seconds
busting with the boys right we should
subscribe we should rate five stars okay
i think
we've mentioned you a couple times you
talked about a bus situation
all right hold on a second save the gold
we're back in literally three seconds
here on nbcs
welcome back to the welcome back to the
rich eisen show here on nbcsn
um and the peacock audience uh knows
that we come back on a little bit sooner
than our nbcsn audience so they've
already enjoyed the
uh stylings if you will of the
delightful pro bowl tackle
of the tennessee titans taylor lawn back
here on the show how are you taylor
i'm great man i'm having a good little
family day today on our off day what do
you got at the spirit halloween store
getting ready for spooktober whoa
i'm pacing back and forth outside of the
store okay
and we're about to dial in the entire
house we my family and i we
thrive in october it just kicks off the
holiday season right you got halloween
yep which is amazing it's my favorite
holiday
okay and then you got then you'll give
thanksgiving it's day i mean everyone if
you love it that's great
for me it pickles on a sandwich i'll
take you to leave it and then there's
christmas right the big shebang that's
my wife's number one go-to
so we're we got a little pre-spooktober
going on right now getting dialed in
getting the basement ready for when the
boys come over because
you know covert rules and all that we're
trying to quarantine all together and
still have a little bit of camaraderie
during the week okay
so now um how many kids do you have
taylor luan i have
i have two kids now i have one a
three-year-old who is in there
probably getting uh nightmares as we
speak and then my youngest is with
somebody right now while we're having a
little
oldest daughter today she's about seven
weeks old now okay great so
um taylor you as a a co-host
of one of the most popular podcasts
that's out there called busting with the
boys knows
that not only did i use this setup to
help promote your podcast but also
uh i as a host of a program uh that
interviews uh
expertly if you don't mind me saying uh
that i i know the answer to questions
before i ask the question
so i know that you had two kids and i
know that they're of an age so young
that
really this is about you and your
enjoyment of halloween
this is not about your kids they'll
never remember this priest
no doubt you're right and this year i
mean this year we usually do like a
super like super scary right the limbs
hanging off the trees and stuff like
that
right there's spider webs that you step
on something that pops out of you
and my wife's like maybe this year we
should do this like a blow up pumpkin
and a colorful frankenstein
so we're gonna do that but the basement
of our house we are going to absolutely
dial into one of the spookiest places
you've ever seen rice i'll send you
pictures
you have to taylor you have to because
you know i've been i've been to some
spooky places
uh what's your favorite costume that
you've ever like what's your tour de
force what would be your
your your top uh your top achievement
in this department my uh probably my
best halloween costume i ever had was
when
the movie titanic came out i was a huge
fan i didn't want to be jack i didn't
want to be rose i didn't want to be the
captain
i was so infatuated with the show i just
wanted to be on the ship
okay so i decided to be a regular just a
cruise man on the ship my mom made me a
whole thing
i definitely died right women and
children first
my mom made me like my own like a little
blazer i had the cool little hat you can
get it in and out burger but without the
in an albergue sign on it i was crushing
it dude it was my favorite thing
college i got a little more lazy i was
uh i was always an off-duty cop right i
had the khaki shorts
tucked into a tank top go over to kids
with paraphernalia saying hey i could do
something about this but i'm off duty
right now that was always my go-to fit
during the whole week
well when you good khakis i would have
thought maybe you were going to harbaugh
but when you said khaki shorts i totally
get it
i know khaki shorts high high high a lot
of thighs shown on the board fantastic
taylor lawn here on the rich isaac let's
talk uh let's talk
national football league football taylor
tonight on nfl network
game day morning season preview i have
to choose who wins each division
uh why should i choose the titans to win
the afc south
i'll tell you what this is a classic
baiting question
that somebody would give a player so
that they can get some bulletin board
information
i think here's what i think i think
since i've gotten to the nfl
the afc south has not has gotten
stronger and stronger every single year
all teams are have done very well
and i think that any time more than ever
than ever since 2014 that's how long
i've been in the nfl thank you
for those of you listening i am a
seasoned vet any
anybody of all those years i mean this
is the best
you know on paper team i've been on i
think the
closest team i've been on and the luxury
of being
in the same offense for three years is
pretty huge too which i which i have not
had
um but i i we've looked good in camp we
obviously had updates and down days but
i would
if i was a bet man which i'm not i would
put every single dollar i've ever made
in my entire life on the title
okay all right now again you are
accusing me of trying to get you to say
something and bait something that we
could use as click bait i'm trying to
get a better at my job
i'm trying to be more informed i'm
talking to an actual left tackle
pro bowl left tackle of a team that
almost made the super bowl that returned
uh
their quarterback and and running back
who got paid
you know what i'm saying also who by the
way also added you davey and clowny over
the weekend have you
you're you're off today so i imagine you
have not seen him in the flesh just yet
no i haven't seen him yet
um i don't know like i don't know davey
and to davian like personally like we
haven't like exchanged phone numbers
gone to have tea together or anything
like that
but what i have done is i've played
against him a lot and i know that he's
extremely talented individual
ben jones our center played in houston
with him so
while we're in the recruitment process
like the saints once sent their whole
you know the whole flock of
upstairs guys down to go see him ben and
i made a quick little facetime call so
we faced time to davey and did have you
answered the phone
he looks fantastic i told him listen
buddy everyone remembers the outback
bowl everyone remembers how you made
that play
the best ball don't lie play of all time
that we can do that together now
with you and me against the world baby
hot beautiful
right he laughed i don't know if it was
a charity laugh or whatever but he gave
me a laugh
24 hours later he agreed in terms of
tennessee titan so did i do something
you close hard to say but i think the
answer is yeah you closed it coffee's
for closing you didn't blow that block
in the
outback bowl did you taylor it was a
deuce no i see rich if you listen to
bustle with the boys uh every monday
night and tuesday on youtube
subscribe and wait five stars for all
the peacock listeners and everybody else
that's on there
you'll know that there was a it was a
gap scheme play and i call the deuce
because they like to loop out that 2i
quite a bit we had uh
george kittle on the on the show one
time and his father came with
yes and then his father tried to tell me
how i was wrong and how that was
actually my fault that i shouldn't have
called the deuce
to that i say phooey it's been too many
years who knows now
it is fuzzy it is fuzzy it's hazy it is
hazy although we do see
oh my god it's either that or
appalachian state which had you know
the anniversary was last week i'm aware
of that you know i see that
those two things i see on my twitter
time on way too much taylor i can't have
it anymore
i won't have it yeah the rookie running
back we have from appalachian state he
but he had the audacity to bring it up
to me and
hey you know 13 13 years ago today did
you know that apple i
said buddy i wasn't even there i called
jake long i called chad henny
all right the boy was in high school
that's my only go-to like
defense mechanism i have right like i
wasn't there don't worry
right instead of instead of didn't make
a bowl game my first year in pretty dark
years of the years i was there that's
not really too much to brag about but
we're on the up and up rich and i'm
happy about that so
uh vrable put him up to it though taylor
right don't you think
rainbow's always doing something i'd say
you want to you want to almost fight a
football coach
you watch the game with him because he's
so condescending the way he talks
like we had a punt block last year or
something then he was like well why
would you guys do that well like let's
just bad football why would you guys
coach that mm-hmm
he's just he's he's on it he likes to be
the top dog and he's definitely when
ohio state's been playing michigan
lately he has every right to play
well you know look i don't want to get
you in trouble with the boss though but
what
i don't know if i've had you on since
the draft what'd you think of his like
blue man group
the situation that he had in his draft
uh house
i think it was i i think it was solid
these kids are hilarious
so it was right up their alley just
trying to go viral real quick and it
worked
we missed 100 of the shots you don't
take wayne gretzky said that so i
appreciate it i like it i like a little
thinking outside the block
i love it look i know you're strolling
around outside of a of a uh
of a uh halloween store right now but
just to
get brass tacks here uh taylor how good
how good is this team seriously you've
been on a ton of good teams you
damn near made the super bowl last year
um nobody's really talking about your
team you can use that as a as a card to
play as well
um how good are the tennessee titans
entering 2020
in your estimates to be honest with you
we have
how we have a huge test in front of us
week one right they
withdrew lock finishing four and one uh
the way their defense is coming along
bradley chubb sounds like he's gonna be
healthy he's an extremely good past
young pass rusher
von miller obviously a walking hall of
famer in the nfl
i think we'll have a lot of questions
answered after that first game
and that's it just one game did you just
one game at a time me did you just do
that no i'm a one game at a time guys
i'm not trying to be on anybody's
bulletin board at this point i'm trying
to play some good ball
man i don't want to go in my team
meeting tomorrow and ravel popping up
articles the tale of one of the rich
eisen shows me and we're this that the
other
right can't do it man can't do it uh i
mean what if i came up i've seen braves
exposed too many guys
all right so you know you want to talk
up your quarterback tanil because again
nobody's talking about him
and he was dynamite last year he's
i think he's thrown some good balls i
think you know
when you're in camp my biggest thing is
hey focus on like just being ready to
play the first game right i don't even
worry about how this guy's doing that
guy's doing
right he's thrown so many good balls in
champ that keith carter our online coach
will literally stop in the middle of our
film and say hey just watch this throw
real quick
he's put some dimes out there man and
he's got a great leadership presence
so he comes in somebody messes up he's
not afraid to tell him that they messed
up
and he takes criticism as well too so
i'm i'm excited for him
i wish i could give you more rich do i
feel it i feel the animosity right now
like i'm never having it's not
animosity it's just like how would you
like it if you had me on
and i said i'm just taking it one show
at a time i mean i'm busting with the
boys like if that's the game i brought
to your
pod you know yeah i'd be i think i'd be
pretty i'd be pretty disappointed i'm
not gonna i hate myself right now i'm
gonna make you feel better i hate myself
come on you just say you know what
you're gonna take care of von miller and
then the next week the jaguars are
tanking anyway
right i mean come on put it out there
taylor i mean just let's go one by one
here
win win win right down the line you
could say what do you think's going on
in jacksonville what's your thoughts on
jacksonville right now
in the tournament like look at you
turning the tables
i mean they had a good solid offensive
line they're quarterbacks good gardener
minchi he showed a lot of promise last
year yeah but leonard fournette he's a
huge key right thousand yard back the
last two years
right get ready yannick and doc way and
i did say that right he's a good friend
of mine he also sometimes is not my
friend based on
how well the game is going there they
have some good players with there
claire's campbell is now in baltimore
how about baltimore too
my goodness they're stacked up there i
like it see that's the way to turn the
tables taylor start talking football man
start talking football what do you think
about the the chiefs though
what do you think my home my home
strikes me as the kind of guy that gets
a half a billion dollar contract and
says i'm done
[Music]
he's the man he's awesome yeah i think
right he's just playing video games with
his hands down his pants sitting on the
couch right now he's not ready for
something i got that bank
all right so let's talk about your pod
before i let you go because i know you
want to talk about it
uh i'm asking you for your advice here
okay because yeah few
last few times you've come on i've
talked about you hosting busting with
the boys
and i don't mention will compton's name
and it really pisses me off
do i keep do i just again i know i'm
talking about it on on live quadcast we
call it the quadcast because it's four
different methods of communication right
now
so um do i just keep it up do i just
just piss him
like do i just piss it up piss him off
what do you think just keep going here's
the thing about wc we won't even say his
name right now
nothing about wp he is
the brains the operation he's everything
in this podcast i'm the guy that shows
up for an hour hey was that good yeah it
was all right there okay i'm out of here
i'm done i gotta go be a family man
right
yes will has has put all the ingredients
in this thing
and he stirred everything up got
everything together preheated the oven
to 425 and i
all i did was put it in the oven you
know what i'm saying that's all i did to
help out
so i think it's only fitting that we
keep busting some shots and just call
them wc don't give them any credit
cara lawrence podcast on busting with
the boys subscribe rate five stars
you know what it's great it's probably
not a five star podcast but don't rate
us for
disrespectful can i can i be
disrespectful and piss him off right now
anyway taylor
what team is he on right now
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what you want to talk
about impressing people man will
confident came into the titans
looking good you know i think we i think
we led the league in the most caucasian
white linebackers
and he uh he's shining out of all of
them he's been doing a great job man
so do you have a motor in the bus or
have you totally given up that someone's
got to sit on a bus to be on your
podcast that's why it's called blessing
with the boys like what like what
come on now if you just just give it up
and just just go to the studio and just
you know i'm not going to go into the
studio what we can do if we can get
a nice little cool space we're actually
looking to rent the space right now
put the bus right in the middle of the
whole place maybe make a little
storefront
sell some stuff with rich eisen face on
it you know what i'm saying not not pay
you a dime for anything but you don't
use your likeness
okay the whole the old ncaa move you
know what i'm saying
like half the people on red bubble that
i see mocking off my mugs right now i'm
coming after
very shortly those people you're going
after oh yeah damn straight i see
everything out there
i see everything out there oh yeah i'm a
litigious you don't want to mess with me
i'll tell you what i don't want to mess
with your vocabulary either because
litigious out of nowhere that's pretty
impressive
i went to michigan taylor swift
we both did i ain't saying leticia i'll
tell you that okay
when when you see rich eyes and t-shirts
coming out and the bustling with the
boys or school vibe
ignore us all right let us make some
money and move on
taylor you take care of yourself man
we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna check in with you um and
just stay safe is everybody uh it's your
whole team's of serious this last
serious question is your whole team like
locked in that nobody's doing anything
stupid that you're not concerned when
you're gonna go on a road that
everybody's gonna actually lock in
and do the right thing and mask up and
get you through the season is that
conversation happened you hop
you convinced or what i would say that
we have a good group of guys for sure
and i think there's so many rules and
there's so many fines and the new cba
you can't find somebody to rescind the
fine
i think people even if they're thinking
like hey maybe i could go oh maybe i
could do this maybe i could go see this
person
you start messing with people's game
checks and stuff like that people will
button up real fast i think i think
we're going to be smart
i think we got to get past this first
week we get past this first week playing
ball
and there's not a big spike or there i
don't think there's been any positive
tests right everyone's pretty negative
i think that's the the news i don't
really follow it but right
it seems like there's been very little
to none chases if that's the case
and we keep that going through week one
i think we're seeing a full 16 game
season those playoffs are gonna look
money in the bank maybe i can't wait
knock on wood if you're with me taylor
lujan everybody okay thanks for the call
man busting with the boys with the
wc who's on what team now what teams
baby which he did just to make sure that
it's a nice geographically sound bus
location for your podcast
which by the way i'm i'm happy to come
on taylor whenever you want i'll just
take it one question at a time and hope
for the best
i'll tell you what it's nice to see you
finally coming around because before it
was
i had to make these list of demands you
may i have to follow these things and
now finally
you're coming around i like that thank
you you got it taylor you take care of
best to your family
enjoy that shopping for uh the priest
spooktober
oh you as well have a great day okay you
got it that's terrible on one of our
favorite guests
god a guy cracks me up hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here